I'm super hyped to show you the first
look with the new Google pixel 8 and
Google pixel 8 Pro phones thanks to
Google for sponsoring this video just
take a little look at how beautiful
these colors are so this is the pixelate
Pro in the bay color it also has kind of
like a matte finish on the back whereas
the pixel 8 has more of a glossy finish
my sister and I are also going to be
doing a live stream to celebrate the
launch of these phones on October 11th
so stay tuned for all of the information
I'll be scheduling here on my channel so
you'll have all of the details and you
can sign up ahead of time so that you
can watch it when we're actually live